typically when the SEC does something
like this people either settle or they
you know they hire lawyers and they hire
crisis PR firms and they just quietly
fight you've decided to do something
quite unusual you-you-you sued the SEC
back and you have taken this fight into
sort of a very public forum so can you
explain why what drove your decision to
do that I've always fought for principle
and fought for truth being able to live
with myself is probably the most
important thing to me that defines me
and if you follow that path for truth
and you fail then at least you know
you've walked that path which is true to
the self I had no choice but to fight
for my truth for 15 years I've worked
tirelessly to save more than 240
companies from liquidation and 700,000
jobs associated with those companies and
this just isn't right it's just not
correct and I needed to fight for that
truth and I had to be public because I
have tens of thousands of employees and
their families who depend on me so to
sit quiet and to fight from what the
background would have given great fear
to my people that I was backing away and
that something was wrong now let's talk
for a moment about the sort of the heart
of the SCC's action case isn't quite the
right word in this but so so they're
they're basically suggesting that you
you exercise discretion or too much
discretion or discretion that you
perhaps weren't supposed to have in
terms of characterizing the the loans in
these portfolios they said you didn't
mark them down to reflect the real
performance of some of these companies
and the way they were paying back the
loans and the interest that they owed
you know what did they get wrong I mean
are you saying that that entire premise
is wrong or is your argument that you
actually had the right to do this and
the investors knew it I mean use my
good-faith business judgment so first of
all yes I think this whole fund has been
built
on the use of my good faith business
judgment but everything I did was fully
disclosed and that is I was able to use
the contractual rate of interest in my
trustee reports show exactly how much
interest was paid and then give the you
know the characterization of that loan
that you know the category and so every
investor every very sophisticated
investor in these funds was given actual
information that described exactly what
I was doing and there are no valuations
in these funds there's a categorization
and there's a holding value that comes
with that categorization so frankly I
think that they miss state you know the
facts with with great inaccuracy do you
feel confident that your investors
really understood what they were getting
into and that they were by investing
with you giving you this amount of
discretion over the valuations or the
the characterizations of the investments
it was it was you know a blatant that
face value for them to see exactly what
I was doing and they invested in a
person who buys companies that others
would liquidate and takes a long and
winding path to restructuring so they
knew that they were investing in deeply
distressed company so it would not have
come as any surprise that many of these
companies were still distressed and my
good-faith business judgment is actually
what's at the heart of all our contracts
and yet everything was disclosed in
exactly what the contractual rate was
the categorization and exactly how much
cash got paid so for anyone with any
kind of sophistication the mathematics
was right there for that
what would the consequences have been if
you had more aggressively marked down
the values or the performance levels of
some of these loans what would have
happened well I mean I mean if I would
have default to them if I would have
defaulted them then funding is not
available to them mm-hmm and most of
these companies would have been
liquidated and then of course if the
companies were liquidated then there and
in the assets were gone there was a
broad possibility that the funds would
have unwound but that would have
happened from the very beginning if
every company that didn't pay its full
interest was immediately defaulted had
no access to capital and liquidated then
the funds would not have gotten off the
ground and that was not what the
investors bargained for at the beginning
of this deal is it possible that some of
the investors were hoping to gain
control or more influence over the
operations of the companies or something
is a more direct involvement in the
investments through this default process
is that not that's certainly not my
understanding the claims that the SEC
has made were never claims made by the
investor base these are all new the
investors have asked questions over the
years on categorization or the absence
of full interest but they've never made
these kind of claims they understand
what's at the heart of this contract and
once things were explained to them they
dismissed any questions